on va terminer ce 7 8 avec un autre
sujet parler de philosophie aux enfants
comment s'y prendre c'est la question
que nous allons poser à la prochaine
invité du 7 8 elle organise des ateliers
philo pour les 7-11 ans c'est un manilet
hameau elle va tout nous dire avant de
être triturer nos méninges du repos tout
de même quelques pressions conseils à
présent par Marie-Thérèse rose président
du Réseau karmaad pour le maintien à
domicile comment se relaxer facilement
chez soi elle va nous dire ça
conditionnement
la lumière
l'installation
le moment choisi en quelques minutes
apprendre à se relaxer à se déstresser
des petits exercices pratiques présentés
par Marie-Thérèse Ross c'est la
présidente du réseau karmaad pour le
maintien à domicile elle est surtout
kinésithérapeute et gérontologue tout
est parti d'un constat c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui devrait apprendre être
appris très jeune si on apprenait déjà
aux personnes respirer il y a deux
personnes sur toi qui respire malgrandis
aux personnes respirées enlève les
épaules les poumons ils sont pas dans
les épaules donc voyez ce sont des
choses très basiques qu'on croit savoir
et qu'on sait pas
pour savoir comment faire il suffit
d'appliquer une méthode toute simple
basée sur la respiration profonde tout
d'abord respirer doit être naturel et ne
pas forcer ses mouvements première leçon
on inspire on appuie sur ses côtes pour
sentir l'air dans son corps et on
souffle tel un accordéon deuxième leçon
on inspire lentement toujours par le nez
on gonfle le ventre et on souffle par la
bouche en l'en trouvant un peu il faut
que le mouvement soit harmonieux comme
créer un va-et-vient d'air qui va
apaiser les battements du cœur cette
méthode appelée respiration profonde ou
respiration par le ventre peut aussi
aider à l'endormissement
enfin troisième leçon on inspire
doucement jusqu'au maximum on serre le
ventre en bloquant la respiration
pendant 10 secondes l'air va nettoyer
l'intérieur du corps et on expire en
rejetant le maximum d'air le principe
souffle et le double de ce que l'on
inspire
inspirez très bien
parce que c'est vraiment efficace et
c'est vrai qu'avec le travail je pense
que justement ça va permettre d'évacuer
les grosses tensions qu'il y a je suis
sûre même que ça doit apporter beaucoup
quand on a des problèmes de sommeil
peut-être et c'est la simplicité que je
trouve bien parce que on peut refaire
facilement on fatigue quand même en
prenant de l'âge et je pense que c'est
une bonne chose pour faire un petit
temps de repos dans la journée des
exercices dit à la minute que l'on peut
faire chez soi ou sur son lieu de
travail il ne crée pas d'endormissement
mais offre une pause salutaire dans des
journées souvent très chargées
maintenant que nous sommes relaxés on va
philosopher avec Anne-sophie chilard
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste aussi
auteur plusieurs ouvrages à votre actif
vous animez des ateliers philo pour les
7 11 ans depuis le mois d'octobre à
Magny-les-Hameaux cela va se poursuivre
jusqu'au mois de mai prochain de la
philo pour les 7-11 ans c'est possible
c'est possible on parle de quoi en
philosophie à partir de 7 ans des
questions philosophiques en fait tous
les parents et grands-parents savent ça
les enfants se les posent naturellement
quels parents n'a pas entendu son enfant
lui demander ce qu'on devient après la
mort pourquoi en existe
des questions comme ça en fait les
enfants se les posent naturellement donc
moi je suis juste là pour accompagner
leur réflexion et mettre en contact une
dizaine d'enfants et en fait le débat
très vite se met en route entre eux
voilà alors vous allez nous dire quels
sont les techniques justement pour les
réussir à avoir des à échanger avec eux
autour de la philosophie on va juste
partir dans les rues de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec cette
question que nous sommes allés vous
poser comment parler de philosophie aux
enfants votre avis
soit de manière marrante soit on leur
apportant des questions auxquelles il y
a pas forcément de réponse
qu'est-ce que c'est le bonheur pour eux
enfin comment est-ce qui pourquoi est-ce
qu'il est heureux à tel moment pourquoi
est-ce qu'il n'est pas heureux à tel
autre instant ce genre de question là il
y a des histoires qui sont en rapport
avec l'orage peut-être pourquoi pas les
thèmes assez simples comme l'amitié
l'amour
je pense que c'est des thèmes qui
pourraient les toucher plus facilement
et pourquoi pas la philo en images
aujourd'hui on fait bien l'anglais en
images et la filo en images ça pourrait
être intéressant comme approche
je sais pas on leur racontant des
histoires sur les anciennes histoires là
enfin que les vieux auteurs
moi je pense que c'est comme ça qu'on
peut essayer de leur parler doucement
enfin gentiment parce que c'est quand
même des sujets complexes qu'il faut
aborder de manière plutôt ludique et
puis sous façon humoristique pour des
enfants
des histoires des contes des images
également on a pu entendre les parents
les grands-parents là sont sur la bonne
voie oui alors évidemment toutes ces
façons là d'aborder la philosophie avec
les enfants sont valables lors des
ateliers en fait moi ce que j'essaye de
mettre en place c'est un espace de
dialogue avec eux pour leur permettre
encore une fois de dialoguer entre eux
et finalement on est à une époque où on
parle beaucoup aux enfants on les laisse
pas mal s'exprimer par rapport à
d'autres générations mais on les laisse
très rarement s'exprimer sur ces
questions là qui sont des questions que
que tout le monde se pose alors il y a
une dame qui parlait de bonheur de
d'amitié effectivement donc ils vivent
ça mais ils ont très peu l'occasion d'en
parler et finalement il suffit que je
lance une question pour que très vite le
dialogue se met en place souvent ce sont
des enfants qui ne se connaissent pas
entre eux et donc c'est assez
impressionnant parce que il se met en
place un dialogue entre eux très
constructif
parce que c'était thème pas forcément
évident vous posez ces questions lors
des différents ateliers pourquoi on rêve
pourquoi on existe aussi tu arrives à
répondre à ça alors ils arrivent pas du
Dakota non du tac au tac non en fait il
passe par leur expérience personnelle
donc au départ c'est un dialogue autour
de moi j'ai vu il m'est arrivé ceci
m'est arrivé cela et donc chacun
rebondit et au fur et à mesure en fait
la pensée se construit en se confrontant
à celle des autres et et finalement on
se rend compte que les les grandes les
grandes pensées philosophiques humaines
sont déjà présentes dans les enfants il
exprime juste avec leur vocabulaire
alors il y a des prédispositions
philosopher oui tous les enfants peuvent
philosopher et se sentent même fier
quand ils sortent effectivement face à
des questions aussi vastes de se dire
que ils ont une part de réponse alors ça
leur rapporte quoi plus de confiance en
eux justement quelques certitudes pas
forcément quand on fait de la
philosophie on repart pas avec des
certitudes on a peut-être même plus de
questions qu'avant tout à fait alors
c'est ce qui est amusant c'est ce que je
leur dis et ce qui est signé à l'aise
pardon au départ c'est que on n'a pas de
réponse même les plus grands savants
même les philosophes qui ont réfléchi à
ces questions là finalement n'ont pas
trouvé une réponse donc ça déjà bon il
se sentent à l'aise parce qu'ils se
disent si bon même si les adultes et les
syndront pas la réponse
et même moi je leur dis moi je ne
connais pas la réponse à cette question
donc ça les met à l'aise ça les met en
confiance et puis ça les met à l'aise
aussi par rapport à une expression orale
donc là il y a des brides des
prédispositions plutôt par rapport à
cette à cette expression orale il y en a
qui s'exprime plus ou moins bien mais
finalement ça les met à l'aise par
rapport à leur propre pensée et c'est le
but de ces ateliers et c'est qu'ils se
sentent capables de réfléchir et de se
positionner par rapport à leur propre
conviction là c'est à partir de 7 ans
plus jeune c'est plus difficile d'avoir
de faire de la philosophie non il existe
des ateliers pour plus jeune moi c'est
vrai que cette once c'est un âge qui me
plaît particulièrement parce que d'une
part les enfants de cet âge-là ont une
capacité plus grande à s'exprimer ils
ont un vocabulaire plus riche ils ont
des expériences de vie aussi beaucoup
plus riches et puis c'est un âge surtout
où il y a pas de toute tabou par exemple
par rapport à des adolescents ou des
enfants plus âgés entre 7 et 11 ans
finalement voilà c'est plus facile il y
a pas tellement peur du regard des
autres de ce qu'on peut dire non parce
que ensuite ça va leur permettre d'être
meilleur en philo alors devenir des
littéraire avoir des bonnes notes au bac
alors c'est une approche qui est
totalement différente évidemment de
l'approche
voilà c'est ça c'est de la philosophie
autrement c'est une pratique
philosophique plus que de la philosophie
telle qu'on le l'enseigne en tout cas en
France il y a d'autres pays dans
lesquels la pratique philosophique est
enseignée vraiment à l'école et ça c'est
très intéressant en France on est plutôt
sur une un apprentissage des hauteurs
des pensées etc
justement alors c'est très nouveau enfin
c'est nouveau ça a une dizaine d'années
et donc ça nous vient des États-Unis il
y a le professeur Lippmann qui avait
commencé à réfléchir autour de ça mais
il y a un mouvement en France de nouveau
philosophe de qui veut instaurer des
nouvelles pratiques philosophiques et
donc ça avec les enfants dans les
entreprises
voilà enfin c'est une nouvelle façon
d'aborder la philosophie en la pratique
en soi-même ce qu'on fait les grands
philosophes comme Socrate par exemple au
début de la philosophie prochaine
atelier 24 novembre 17h30 à l'estaminet
à Magny-les-Hameaux pourquoi on rêve ce
sera le thème de celui-ci il y en aura
d'autres tout au long de l'année
jusqu'en mai 2013 c'est gratuit faut
réserver quels sont les informations
pratiques pratiquement parlant il faut
appeler à l'estaminet et puis réserver
voilà c'est gratuit et ensuite il y a un
petit goûter donc les parents
n'assistent pas je l'ai pas dit mais
c'est important
puisque ils sont tous libres voilà ils
sont plus libres de discuter entre eux
pour ne pas frustrer les parents ça se
termine par un petit dessin en fait on
laisse une trace écrite ou dessiner de
ce qu'on s'est dit pendant cet atelier
pour que les parents puissent voir un
peu ce qui s'est dit et donc il y a un
petit goûter et un apéritif pour les
parents à la suite pour qu'on puisse
échanger tous ensemble avec les parents
pour ceux qui viennent pas venir
participer aux ateliers ou en tout cas
en introduction ils peuvent toujours se
référer à d'autres ouvrages qui ont été
publiés pense pas bêtes et questions
philo en envoient les couvertures vous y
parlez de quoi c'est des clés aussi pour
les parents là alors là ce sont des des
bac philo que j'ai mené avec des enfants
qui ont qui qui ont donné naissance à
une rubrique dans un magazine pour
enfant dont est tiré ce livre et ça
permet notamment aux parents d'avoir
quelques réponses
et puis surtout ça ça permet de dialogue
pas les réponses puisque les réponses
n'existent pas mais en tout cas en
rentrant et par an effectivement
d'amorcer aussi un dialogue
philosophique merci donc d'être venu sur
ce plateau Anne-Sophie chilard qui anime
en ce moment des ateliers de philosophie
sur Manille les hameaux les
renseignements qui se sont affichés
rendez-vous auprès de l'estaminet pour
avoir un peu plus de détails merci donc
d'être venu sur ce plateau une dernière
information pour terminer ce s78 Benoît
Hamon étant en ce moment à Trappes il
est présent lors de l'ouverture de la
première antenne pour l’île-de-france du
réseau envie il va signer à cette
occasion les premières embauches en
emploi d'avenir des Yvelines Benoît
Hamon qui est ministre de l'Économie et
sociale et solidaire à l'antenne envie
attrape emploi aujourd'hui 17 salariés
dans 11 personnes en insertion et nous
avons parlerons bien évidemment lors de
nos prochaines éditions on se retrouve à
lundi avec de nouveaux invités en direct
pour faire un point complet sur
l'actualité des Yvelines demain vendredi
Johanna Caudry pour l'édition du
week-end récapitulatif de toute
l'actualité notamment très politique qui
s'est écoulé depuis lundi je vous
retrouve moi dès lundi je vous souhaite
déjà un bon weekend excellente soirée
merci beaucoup